il marque mais joe journaliste à la crtv
la radio télévision nationale du
cameroun ma question s'adresse au
président de la république française
seul président les africains et
particulièrement les camerounais sont
témoins des concours financiers et de la
qualité des matériels militaires que
l'occident apporte à l'ukraine en guerre
lorsque l'on sait que les pays africains
en difficulté économique ou même en
conflit ont du mal à recevoir pareille
bienveillance par et assistance monsieur
le président comment assumer vous ces
deux poids deux mesures je vous remercie
d'abord
je pense que on dit souvent quand
j'écoute je lis beaucoup
d'approximations sur ce qui se passe en
ukraine
et je ne ferai pas
de comparaison excessive en ukraine vous
avez un pays souverain
dont la souveraineté l'intégrité
territoriale a été violée par une
agression unilatérale d'un pays voisin
la russie
c'est comme ça qu'il faut le qualifie
c'est une guerre lancée par la russie
les règles qui sont les nôtres
la charte des nations unies les textes
que nous avons signé que la russie
d'ailleurs a également signé en tant que
membre de l' os c'est eux font qu'elle a
violé à peu près tous ses engagements
internationaux
le choix qui a été fait par les
européens
premièrement n'est en aucun cas de
participer à cette guerre mais de la
reconnaître et de la nommer là où je
vois trop souvent de l'hypocrisie
particulier sur le continent africain je
vous le dis avec beaucoup de calme et de
sérénité à ne pas savoir qualifier une
guerre qui en est une et à ne pas savoir
dire qu'il a lancée parce qu'à des
pressions diplomatiques je ne suis pas
dupe m'enfin faut dire les choses on vit
mieux
nous nous avons décidé de tout faire
pour stopper cette guerre comme l'a dit
le président et je vous rappelle que moi
même quelques jours avant je suis allé
en russie en ukraine pour essayer de
l'empêcher
tout faire pour la stopper sans y
participer ce faisant que font les
européens
il sanctionne la russie pour bloquer son
effort de guerre
et c'est dans tous les cénacles europe
et cénac pardon internationaux de
l'isoler diplomatiquement c'est là où
nous avons besoin de vous parce que
sinon ce schéma se reproduira à l'envi
c'est pas l'ordre international que nous
voulons qui repose sur la coopération et
respect de la souveraineté tchèque et
enfin nous aidons l'ukraine a résisté
les aides économiques et financières
dz prenant les réfugiés des aides
militaires en livrant du matériel
c'est ça la situation très précise et je
ne vois pas sur le sol africain des pays
qu'ils soient dans une situation
comparable étant agressé par une
puissance voisine où nous aurions à nous
poser
tel sujet par contre je vois des pays
qui ont pu être déstabilisé par le
terrorisme
ça c'est tout à fait vrai et vous parlez
là
un chef d'état qui al'honneur d'être à
la tête d'un pays qui s'est engagé au
combien mais je vous le dis avec
beaucoup de clarté monsieur en afrique
nous n'avons pas simplement livré des
armes nous avons envoyé des troupes à la
demande d'un état souverain qui était le
mali et de l'organisation régionale qui
était la cedeao pour la défense de sa
souveraineté nationale nous avons donc
fait beaucoup plus que pour l'ukraine je
vous parle avec la gravité d'un chef
d'état qui a eu à enterrer des soldats
parce qu'ils sont venus sur le sol
africain défendre la souveraineté d'un
état qui n'était pas le leur
c'est ça la réalité s'il ya deux poids
deux mesures
ce deux poids deux mesures et dans
l'autre sens que celui que vous avez
évoqué
l'armée française à la demande du mali
en 2013 est intervenu pour stopper les
terroristes qui faisait route vers
bamako puis l'armée française à la
demande de l'état malien et de la cedeao
est resté pur protéger et si aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas un califat territoriale au
mali c'est parce qu'il ya eu l'armée
française et que des dizaines de nos
enfants sont morts sur le sol africain
pour lutter contre le terrorisme
allez voir beaucoup d'autres que la
france pour leur demander les deux poids
deux mesures la france est le pays qui
s'est le plus engagé pour des états
africains à leur demande et pour leur
sécurité par contre nous le faisons dans
un cadre clair
à la demande d'un état souverain et pour
lutter contre le terrorisme quand ce
cadre n'a pu été remplies après les deux
coups d'état militaires roumanie et les
choix de la junte nous avons décidé de
partir de réorienter notre dispositif et
ce à la règle
maintenant nous avons des politiques de
coopération militaire avec de nombreux
pays africains
le cameroun en fait partie qui passe par
deux
des livraisons de la formation et
partenariats et c'est sur ce cette route
que nous continuerons d'avancer de
consolider le lien qui est le nôtre sur
le plan militaire voilà je ne peux pas
être plus exhaustif et précis pour faire
la différence entre des situations vous
avez évoqué rappeler la réalité de
l'implication de la france